If you're feeling a palpable
sexual excitement in the air,
it's probably because the vice
presidential debate was tonight.
-Oh! There they...
-(applause and cheering)
Tim Kaine and Mike Pence,
otherwise known as
white guy 37B
and white guy 55C squared off...
Hang on. That's Mr. Belding and
the dad from That '70s Show.
-It's...
-(laughter)
Jack, will you please
put up the right photos?
No, Jack. That is Ned Flanders
and a bowl of rice.
Please find photos
of the VP candidates.
-All right, that's better. Uh...
-(laughter)
-Now...
-(applause and cheering)
Since we were busy
taping at the time,
we didn't get to see the debate
as it happened,
so we're just assuming
that at some point,
harmonica enthusiast Tim Kaine
did a bitching duet
with John Popper
from Blues Traveler,
and that Mike Pence revealed
he's been a dummy
controlled by Jeff Dunham
this entire time.
(laughter)
Either way, Americans knows next
to nothing about these two.
So comedians, what's a question
they should have been asked
to get the core
of these store-brand white guys?
Louie Anderson.
Have you ever owned stock
in Cracker Barrel?
-HARDWICK: Points. Points.
-(laughter)
-(applause)
-Are you Cracker Barrel?
Brendon Walsh.
What's your favorite
Jimmy Buffett song?
-And you can't say all of them.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Martha Kelly. -KELLY: Oh.
Should 21st century
American women be allowed
to get abortions
or just fake boobs?
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Points. Points.